Oh buddy - markiplier we're right back
into it Wade what is going on over there
I didn't even stop the other judges
doggy you will need to stop anything
you're supposed to just keep going oh
cop puked at me oh it was oh you wait
puke
yeah puke police officer police officer
is here is that's a bad sign right cuz
that's one of the more elite zombies
yeah ah
burnt where are you look back yard why I
was gonna go to this fine stuff
alright ok alright ok it's ok it's ok
it's ok wait I'm coming to help you Wade
we've been [ __ ] around for too long
we need to get down I don't know but
this is some hard dirt this just shoo is
there no faster way to mine because holy
sabotage me Jesus
stop doing that he dodged me you scare
the crap out of me hey lark of it I
don't care what he does
don't do that to me oh my god gonna be
ok Wade I'm gonna collect this uh gravel
so that we can build you you said we
need to gravel right sure don't worry
you said we did know we needed
cobblestone that's right almost done
would you make it a regular stone oh ok
so I don't need a this so Wade lead the
way you know what's going you lead okay
probably make a shovel
um actually tell you go back to the
house or it's already no no we're
staying what happens moving god it's
long no we're staying out we don't have
time to go back we gotta stay out this
night we got to stay I'm gonna end well
I'm putting all my valuables in my bar
here don't put your guns away all the
ones I want to keep just which just
seriously gotta survive but we got to
make progress the viewers are getting
bored like favors telling us subscribers
you're getting bored name name one of
you that is bored ha ha oh yeah has a
doggy
before you you're welcome okay I need
pain pills cuz I'm actually oh no wait I
plenty nevermind I'm good I'm good okay
wait
wait look are you leading the way or are
you just lollygagging about here okay
good I think this is a good way to go I
need this is where we were I think this
is an excellent way to go do you right
back to the house
fake misses this right way too good no
oh no dad oh good this is the other
house this is not the house we were just
in we're in the White House you have a
choice to make wait you stay out with me
you stay out with me and survive or go
run wait
I got a torch I'll I follow you okay
wait where are you going that guy is
fast holy crap that guy is fast wait
help wait help you know you know you
gotta kill it oh my gosh unavailable how
long does it take me to reload goddamn
Wade what's up did you go upstairs I'm
in the Attic putting down torches unlock
door just off the hole I don't have
anything to block out the hole with well
yes I do I have asked fault I put the
[ __ ] in the wrong place oh oh I gotta
get this don't do that
I gotta get the asphalt can you worry
about the thing attacking you how about
you kill it how about you kill it well
yeah why I do it for the god damn it I I
am so much drool on my face I'm not got
to wipe off you break this block I need
to I'm gonna hey yeah I know what would
you block it
why didn't you block it why would you
unblock it Vic it wasn't blocked to
begin with you know what just leave it
we're fine we're fine Wade I'm about to
die but we're fine
Wade I'm gonna have some choice work
with you because you are a poor leader
that's what you are wait I wouldn't
leave I would have inherited a house
Wade idiot how did that get here I told
you how he was blocked by wood this
isn't working Wade Wade I found the
asphalt
now I blocked it off so don't do nothing
I blocked it off you just leave it lie
Wade if we're gonna survive together in
this zombie apocalypse I need your full
cooperation
Wade Wade are you laughing over there
laughing for the best reason okay okay
there to get your drugs you I have
plenty I don't need any more actually
you told me you were out then I said I
had stuff taken anyway Thank You Wade
for the lovely cooperation that we are
enduring and that's what it is
we are enduring each other's company
right now cow what we're gonna do if
we're gonna do what we were supposed to
do which is create a safe haven and then
start mining and making a deeper element
so this game okay correct right right so
I'm start we're just gonna break out
through the side square plus we're gonna
have to do so for calm collected took a
deep breath right we're good huh huh you
want me to get that for you I got that
for you I was gonna wait till morning
nope too late we're going now okay I
hope that those supports aren't really
necessary probably but I don't know yeah
I forgot that some of these things in
this game are like support like burying
Lena Smith okay it looks pretty good out
here I don't see any zombies
oh look clear thing sounds perfectly
normal out sounds fine come on let's go
you ready yeah why not okay so what
we're gonna have to do good to go I
don't know where we're gonna go we're
gonna suffer a lot of fall damage coming
out of here we should wait it's almost
day I miss your weight I'm on the fan
are you let's go Oh jumped why'd you
jump in front of the feds didn't tell
you to jump
it feels pretty safe down here ow oh
that hurt okay
zombies are after you you'll bring it
where are you oh you're in the dark 3 ok
alright so it's about to turn day let's
go find another location oh babe puppy
remember got it
reloading he'll be cover my ass it's
almost day alright we're gonna find
another location through suburbia
seriously look out as it's already
attacking everything out okay let's get
out of Suburbia this Ventura so fast I
know for how big he is used rather agile
I found gasoline good okay let's go
let's go let's go let's get out of here
let's go find some other place because
this is not for us you store a whole
bunch of stuff in one of those houses no
we got to go to a new location it's like
in The Walking Dead when they left they
went to a new place for no reason
graphical glitches Wow
y'okay just appeared are you okay wait
don't worry get away gunshot gone don't
freak out on me yet blade blade shut up
smaran raid Rick AIDS work I think shade
works better and Roarke is guard okay
welcome to the rock and shade show it
were thick yeah yeah if it is heading
Mick are croc shark yes stay are we a
towards the desert why are we going to
the desert because we said we needed
desert is our stand but yeah and then
we're gonna find a place to survive um
okay shut up there's a house I see it
we're gonna get it
wait this isn't the desert what is this
this is the area before the desert
where's the desert oh I see hey isn't
that the house we survived in
it might actually be you want to survive
in there I not well too bad it's not
time for night yet we're gonna have to
keep moving
they got two more minutes of daylight no
we got plenty of daylight it's done not
even noon yet what are you talking about
why you being crazy but we did leave the
house at like 5:00 in the morning yeah
true very good observation um this time
skills in whatever there are a lot of
zombies puppy you shouldn't be you're so
dumb
Wade you're so dumb you should be able
to see yeah yeah see see shut up shut up
you should be able to see those there oh
I'm pretty sure there are more zombies
in there were before I'd say so
okay so we're continuing south we're
going to the desert screw you we're
going to the desert I'm going to the
desert says I'm gonna clear this house
out why cuz there's no houses in the
desert you're just gonna respawn you
know this you told me this
what will spawn they perpetually respawn
didn't use a light yeah but I mean we're
not gonna survive here now get here a
night they'll be back so let's just keep
going to the desert hey put it follow my
lead
I will not lead us astray I'll probably
lead us astray but that's besides that's
what I'm putting all my valuables in my
inventory don't do it don't do it we can
make it you're right
we had a server yeah yeah look at this
it's new the viewers want to see new
look at all this news yes screaming and
crying as we die I see a house
look we're go to the house Oh God is
that legal
uh okay hey any wait wait wait wait wait
have I ever done you wrong I feel like
in another life there were three seasons
of a series of something Oh what what
are you talking about just your house
it's a one-story hey hey just more room
for us to cuddle in all right
you just get nice and cozy we're gonna
sing songs and lullabies look there's a
campfire
i-i-i-i uh Wade yeah I uh
ha ha ha ha I shot it once and it fell
apart what kind of house with that of
bad is nothing else even remember we
came here for a purpose
let's just get it and get out we didn't
even make a shovel
well then let's me I don't have enough
scrap metal I don't think I do either oh
we're gonna die
I led us astray how much sand do we need
uh well this is the last luck I'm
getting I'm 400 for the hills yeah oh
yeah night is like 30 minutes away isn't
it 30 minutes I think so I think more
like 10 seconds okay or 30 minutes game
time uh uh I hate to tell you this I
think we're gonna die I think this is
where our journey ends
we don't wanna die we were gonna show
them new things we did and then we died
right yeah okay this house is in sight
yeah I know let's just get to the house
and then we'll be fine it's oh it's
getting so dark there's so many look
this between here and there you still
having problems well I see a car but
it's a floating Wade you need to sort
your computer out I don't know why oh no
does it only happen when you play with
me
uh no I had it was smaller the other day
too
oh yeah I did build your computer that's
right isn't it yeah you should be he
should come fix it we built it on a
budget and don't you forget it
that's true yeah we need a new budget
are you any good please tell um would I
I have no wood I'll go get wood real
quick cuz I have a fire axe yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes I do you sound so the
acog way tone but you're gonna be uh
saving us I uh this isn't doing very
much
uh Wade how much stamina do you have not
water if you don't have any I don't have
any water what Wade I can't chop this
fast enough wait wait wait I'm trying
great my best way tell me what okay
thank you the help I got it I got it I
got it I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
baby I'm coming with the wood
I got wood baby finally I'm coming back
warm up the bed for right yeah it's warm
are you in no oh God
wait wait wait let me end this is a door
right here I shot my win wait where are
you I'm downstairs at the front wall
that was once open for you oh wait I got
scared I was alone I shot oh I shot a
hole in the house okay shut up shut up
Wade I had no choice you left me with oh
crap things don't work when they
standing on nothing do they you're
shoving couches shop
Wade I'm trying my best
did you loot everything already no I
eluded a safe and that was it
I'm getting out good water
oh I just blurred my contact I can't
even see right now oh that was my
problem before okay good good we're
doing great we're doing great
right buddy right buddy pal you know
we're alive we're alive I don't know for
how long
that's pretty good alive I'm on a dig
I'm gonna build a mine good where we
said we're gonna the first time can't
see anything
chop get your gunk out of your eye and
let's get to work sure I can't ah my
inventory is like full full push it up
with his chest I will this is a perfect
location to hide out for the rest of our
life right right Wade Wade yeah it's
great great doesn't get any better than
this
anyway we're all out of time for this
part hope you're enjoying the series of
nothingness so far oh this is Ben mark
and Wade check out wait Stan
again for his POV and other stuff thank
you also ever watching anything else to
say wait see you later guys see the next
will will be around
or will we will find out by ma man I'm
not even gonna give back thing the time
of day
okie-dokie what's that
you're snipper after experiencing my
body is a machine that I could see and
feel who is rpts what who is our pts who
is that whoa there's another one in the
corner